سنتحدث عن الجديد في المنطقه الوسطى هذه
المره ولن نبدا من منطقه خانيونس قبل قليل
كانت هناك غاره اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا
في منطقه الزوايده وسط قطاع غزه هذا
المنزل اصيب بالدمار نظرا لهذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه وهناك عدد من الاصابات انتشلت
من المكان حسب المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه
ولا معلومات حتى الان عن وقوع شهداء جراء
هذا القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف هذا
المنزل باعتبار ان الغاره الاسرائيليه
وقعت للتو ولم تصدر احصائيه لا مؤقته ولا
رسميه او نهائيه حتى الان وبالتالي في
قادم الدقائق سوف تتضح الصوره بشكل اكبر
حول نتيجه هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه لكنها
لم تكن الغاره الوحيده في منطقه مجاوره
لمنطقه الزوايده وتحديدا في النصيرات
استهدف ف مننزل اخر لعائله الحاج في هذه
المنطقه وسط قطاع غزه ايضا الامر الذي ادى
الى استشهاد سبعه من الفلسطينيين من هذه
العائله واصابه اخرين بجروح حسب المصادر
الطبيه وهذه تعتبر احصائيه مؤقته او لحظيه
كما نسميها باعتبار ان الغارات
الاسرائيليه من هذا النوع التي تدمر
البيوت على رؤوس ساكنيها دون سابق انذار
ودون تحذيرات عاده ما يبقى بعض المفقودين
تحت ركام هذه المنازل ويتعذر على رجال
الدفاع المدني ورجال الاسعاف ان ينتشل
جميع من كانوا بداخل هذا المنزل ساعه
استهدافه بالغارات الاسرائيليه نظرا
للدمار الكبير وقله الامكانيات وخطوره
الموقف حقيقه خلال هذه الساعات من الليل
لا سما وان الغارات الاسرائيليه مستمره
وان انه في مرات سابقه عديده استهدف رجال
الاسعاف او الدفاع المدني بشكل مباشر من
قبل الطائرات المسيره الاسرائيليه عندما
كانوا يقومون باعمالهم في محاوله لانتشال
ناجين او محاصرين او جرحى او انتشال
جثامين الشهداء على ايه حال هذه الغاره في
الوسطى كانت سبقتها عده غارات في منطقه
البريج والمغازي الامر الذي ادى الى سقوط
سبعه شهداء ايضا في استهداف لمجموعه
استشهد اب ونجله وفي استهداف لمدرسه ايواء
في هذه المنطقه في منطقه المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه ايضا استشهد خمسه من الفلسطينيين
واصابه اخرين من النازحين داخل هذه
المدرسه في حين كانت الاحداث الاكثر دمويه
حتى الان هذا اليوم في منطقه خانيونس التي
نتواجد فيها والتي ام امطرت بكثير من
القذائف المدفعيه بالقرب من مستشفى الامل
التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
الامر الذي ادى الى استشهاد
شهيد في هذه المنطقه واصابه اخرين نظرا
لهذا الاستهداف المباشر من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا من قبل المسيرات
الاسرائيليه التي اطلقت عده رصاصات باتجاه
المواطنين الفلسطينيين ساعه الذروه
بالنسبه لتحركاتهم في هذا الشارع المحاذي
الذي تحول الى ما يشبه السوق المؤقته تعرض
فيه بعض المعلبات والمواد الغذائيه التي
تتوفر لاجل اقتنائها من قبل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين نظرا لان هذه المستشفى وهذا
المقر للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تحول الى
مركز ايواء وبالتالي يضم الاف من النازحين
فضلا عن ان هذه المنطقه هي منطقه اصلا
مكتظه بالسكان والمساكن وتشكل قلب مدينه
خانيونس على ايه حال هناك سلسله ايضا من
الغارات الاسرائيليه سبقت هذه الغاره
وتبعت هذه الغاره وسقط فيها شهداء وجرحى
في اجمال الاعداد التي نتحدث عنها هي 31
شهيدا على الاقل في خانيونس خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه